catching some of the world's largest and
most exotic fish is getting easier in
Thailand with the growing popularity of
sport fishing here several new fishing
venues have opened up around Bangkok one
such place is lake monster around an
hour and a half's drive from the Thai
capital here recreational anglers can
come and fish for a variety of large
native and important exotic species some
of them found naturally in the Amazon
River in South America with what its
owner says is 25 thousand fish in a
seven acre pond fishing enthusiasts like
Brendan O'Sullivan are virtually
guaranteed some spectacular catches you
can talk about purists obviously who
want to go and fish on the waters but
the Amazon is a mighty big river and the
chance of catching anything is minimal
the owner says he began stocking the
lake two years ago so his friends could
come and fish but what started as a
hobby has grown into a lucrative
business you don't even have been a
lucky man we have some exotic new
species here haven't I fish they can
grow 2 to 3 metres long I know people
want to come and fish for this big fish
many of them are new friends how are you
doing it man as one of Asia's top
fishing tourism destinations Thailand
attracts plenty of foreigners willing to
pay more than 100 US dollars a day for a
rod to fish with its tropical climate
Thailand can house tropical fish from
other parts of the world and it's become
a breeding center for tropical aquarium
fish for conservation biologist Zeb
Hogan who heads national Geographics
mega fishes project a visit to lake
monster is an opportunity to see rare
and endangered species like the dog
eating catfish reportedly this predator
got its name from old stories of
fishermen baiting hooks with pieces of
dog flesh to catch it I've never seen a
large dog eating catfish in the wild and
this is probably only the third or
fourth time that I've even been able to
handle one of these fish so being at
this pond is a pretty exciting for me
the lakes owner says
none of the fish here were taken from
the wild but were bred in captivity
anglers must release every fish they
catch back into the lake but at the end
of the day from a population biology
perspective this is not negatively
impacting fish stocks this is allowing
anglers to catch rare species without
having to go in the wild and try to
remove a very rare fish from its natural
habitat from a conservation biologists
perspective someone who cares about
endangered species wants to keep
endangered species in the wild alive
this is a good idea Hogan says
artificial lakes like these can play an
important part in helping to preserve
some of the world's largest and rarest
fish species